Os lanzo una pregunta, ¿cuántos de vosotros
recordáis haber visto este meme?
Las malas lenguas dicen que es Sergei Lavrov,
el Ministro de Exteriores ruso intentando
llegar a Belgrado volando por sí mismo después
de que los países de la OTAN que rodean a
Serbia no autorizaran el paso de su avión
por su espacio aéreo.
(Naciones OTAN bloquean el avión del enviado
ruso en la visita a Serbia - AP)
Evidentemente, Lavrov no pudo llegar a Belgrado,
pero quizás este detalle sea el menos importante
de toda esta historia.
Lo importante tiene que ver con otra pregunta:
¿por qué diantres un país como Serbia,
que es uno de los cinco aspirantes oficiales
a entrar en la Unión Europea tenía previsto
recibir con todos los honores al Ministro
de Exteriores de Rusia en medio de la actual
coyuntura político-militar y en plena invasión
rusa de Ucrania?
Los que hayáis visto nuestro último vídeo
sobre Serbia y la historia de Yugoslavia ya
sabréis por dónde van los tiros.
Porque en el actual contexto no todo es tan
sencillo como establecer una división tajante
entre dos bloques: los países pro-Occidente
y los países pro-Rusia.
De hecho, el caso de Serbia nos lanza de bruces
contra otra realidad: la tercera vía.
(“Serbia está orgullosa de no formar parte
de la histeria anti-rusa.”
- Aleksandar Vulin, Ministro del Interior
de Serbia)
(Serbia ignora las sanciones de la UE y asegura
un acuerdo de gas con Putin - VOA)
(29 de mayo de 2022 - "Es el precio más favorable
de Europa.
[...] Firmaremos un contrato de tres años,
y mañana o pasado mañana discutiremos las
cantidades de gas.
[...] Serbia necesita mayores cantidades de
gas, pero si se me permite decirlo, tendremos
un invierno seguro y habrá más conversaciones
para determinar cuánto nos costará la gasolina".
- Aleksandar Vučić ((Pron: Vuchich)), Presidente
de Serbia)
Teniendo todo esto en cuenta, cualquiera podría
pensar que la posición serbia está determinada
única y exclusivamente por una cuestión
de dinero: es decir, por ejemplo, echarse
en brazos del Kremlin para escapar de la escalada
de precios del gas y del petróleo que se
está experimentando a nivel internacional.
Sin embargo, aunque lo cierto es que el dinero
siempre influye, en esta ocasión no resulta
algo tan sencillo de explicar.
En este vídeo os vamos a contar por qué
hoy por hoy la república más grande surgida
de la desintegración de la antigua Yugoslavia
sigue queriendo llevarse bien con Rusia a
pesar de la guerra de Ucrania y de querer
entrar en la UE.
[Pero antes, os hago una pregunta: ¿Alguna
vez os habéis preguntado cómo invierten
sus fortunas los estados más ricos?
¿Habéis oído hablar de los fondos soberanos?
¿Cuáles son las mayores huchas públicas
del mundo?
¿En qué se diferencian los fondos soberanos
de Noruega, China y Emiratos Árabes?
Para responder a todas estas preguntas no
os podéis perder el último vídeo de Si
lo Hubiera Sabido, el canal de información
financiera de Mutuactivos con el que participamos.
Os dejamos el enlace en la descripción.]
Dicho esto, regresemos
a Serbia.
Serbia tiene una historia bastante convulsa
respecto a todo aquello que habitualmente
identificamos con Occidente o al menos con
el eje atántico.
Claro que sobre está cuestión y sobre la
formación de la actual Serbia ya os contamos
muchos detalles en un reciente vídeo que
os dejamos en la descripción.
Pero, para los que todavía no lo hayais visto,
aquí un breve resumen:
(El punto álgido en las malas relaciones
entre Serbia, Estados Unidos y el resto de
aliados atánticos tuvo lugar en 1999, cuando
aviones de la OTAN bombardearon durante casi
tres meses posiciones militares y gubernamentales
a lo largo y ancho de toda Serbia, incluida,
por supuesto, su capital, Belgrado.
La intervención de la OTAN tuvo como objetivo
detener los crímenes de lesa humanidad que
se estaban cometiendo en el marco del conflicto
que mantenía la extinta República Federal
de Yugoslavia con los independentistas kosovares
de etnia albanesa.
En concreto hablamos de un intento de limpieza
étnica contra las minorías de origen albanes.)
Pues bien, la cuestión es que a pesar de
que la política serbia ha cambiado mucho
desde entonces, este tipo de sucesos históricos
suelen dejar tras de sí una importante huella.
En este caso, por ejemplo, explican, porque
buena parte de la sociedad serbia sigue viendo
con mucho recelo a la propia OTAN y, en general,
a todo lo que tenga que ver con la comunidad
occidental.
Y también explica la popularidad que sigue
teniendo Rusia entre los serbios.
Al fin y al cabo Moscú se posicionó del
lado yugoslavo en las instituciones internacionales.
Por ejemplo, en un pasado estudio de Gallup
realizado en 2016, más del 60% de los serbios
manifestaron que seguían percibiendo a la
OTAN como una amenaza real.
Esta fue de hecho una de las peores valoración
que la Organización del Tratado del Atlántico
Norte obtuvo en cualquier país del centro
y el este de Europa.
En esa misma encuesta, por cierto, el país
con mejor opinión de la OTAN no fue otro,
que…
¡Oh Sorpresa!
Kosovo.
Pero eso no es todo.
Serbia también está a la cola de Europa
en cuanto al apoyo popular a su adhesión
a la Unión Europea.
En 2019 menos de la mitad de los serbios estaban
a favor de pertencer al club comunitario y
en torno al 60% desconfiaba de las instituciones
europeas.
Y todo ello a pesar de que la propia Unión
Europea le ha dado a Serbia durante los últimos
años más de 2.800 millones de euros en ayudas
al desarrollo.
[¿Puede ser este un ejemplo de cómo las
instituciones europeas gastan dinero sin ton
ni son?
No sé, ahí lo dejo]
Y ojo que ahí no contamos otras ayudas que
a título individual han entregado otros países
miembtos, porque en ese caso la suma prácticamente
se duplica.
Y sí, por si alguno se lo está preguntando,
sí, la Unión Europea es de lejos el mayor
donante de Serbia.
Claro que si se lo preguntais a los propios
serbios solo 3 de cada 10 tienen esa impresión.
¿Y el resto?
Pues la mayoría os dirán que Rusia.
¿Por qué?
Bueno, lo iréis descubriendo a lo largo de
este vídeo.
El caso, sin embargo, es que lo más curioso
de todo es que las rencillas históricas no
son ni mucho menos el motivo principal que
explica la equidistancia de Belgrado entre
Bruselas y Moscú.
¿Por qué Serbia no ha terminado de integrarse
en la Unión Europea ni tampoco se está dando
prisa para hacerlo?
Pues, queridos amigos, la respuesta es simple:
su falta de interés por acometer las reformas
que Bruselas exige.
Belgrado apuesta por alargar todo el tiempo
que pueda su situación actual, es decir,
estar fuera, pero en cierto modo, dentro de
la Unión.
Ahora bien, ¿Por qué este tira y afloja
con la Unión Europea?
¿Si la sociedad serbia desconfia tanto de
Occidente por qué mantienen su candidatura
a formar parte del club comunitario?
¿Qué explica realmente los lazos entre Rusia
y Serbia?
Preguntas importantes para uno de los países
más desconocidos de Europa.
Pues bien, descubrámoslo.
(JUGANDO CON LOS SENTIMIENTOS)
Si hay algo que los rusos han sabido explotar
desde la desintegración de Yugoslavia y la
posterior formación en 2006 de Serbia como
estado independiente tal y como hoy lo conocemos,
eso ha sido la llamada “hermandad eslava”.
Una hermandad que abarca tanto la historia
como el terreno político e, incluso, la identidad
religiosa.
Ahí tenemos, sin ir más lejos, el caso de
la alianza religiosa entre el Patriarcado
de Moscú, esto es, la Iglesia ortdoxoma rusa,
y la de Serbia.
Una alianza que busca ganar influencia tanto
dentro como fuera de estos dos países.
Por ejemplo, el Patriarcado de Moscú y el
Patriarcado de Serbia llevan años tratando
de influir juntos en la sociedad y el gobierno
de Montenegro, un país que se independizó
de Serbia en el año 2006.
Fijaos.
(En Montenegro, un país que es algo más
pro-occidental que Serbía, más del 60% de
la población se declara seguidora de la Iglesia
Ortodoxa Serbia.
Pues bien, en Montenegro, la Iglesia Ortodoxa
Serbia aprovecha su gran cantidad de seguidores
para participar activamente en la vida política
del país, organizando, participando y promoviendo
mítines y protestas políticas, como por
ejemplo manifestaciones contra la OTAN o las
instituciones y la forma de vida occidentales.)
(Activistas anti-OTAN de Montenegro organizan
fiesta de Año Nuevo.
La oposición pro-rusa está organizando un
partido anti-OTAN en la capital Podgorica
[...] con la bendición de la Iglesia Ortodoxa
Serbia en Montenegro.
- Balkan Insight)
Pero la religión es sólo uno de los medios
que la Rusia de Putin ha encontrado para influir
en la sociedad serbia y en el área de influencia
de este país.
Otro ejemplo lo tenemos en los medios de comunicación.
En Serbia, Rusia ha realizado importantes
inversiones en los medios de comunicación
e, incluso, cuenta con publicaciones de tirada
gratuita.
Medios que apoyan a los mandamases locales
a cambio de difundir la propia agenda política
de Moscú.
De hecho, esta situación llega a tal punto
que, por decirlo de alguna forma, hablar de
medios de comunicación serbios y medios ruosos
viene a ser como hablar de la misma cosa.
(“Belgrado proclama oficialmente que la
adhesión a la UE es una prioridad, pero siempre
se ha alejado de las políticas europeas que
van en contra de los intereses rusos, mientras,
los medios progubernamentales se hacen eco
de los feroces mensajes que provienen del
Kremlin”.
- France24)
Pero…
Por supuesto, si hay un tema que Rusia sabe
que aún genera escozor en la sociedad serbia
y que puede utilizar para alejar a los serbios
de la influencia occidental, esto no es otro
que Kosovo.
Kosovo es reconocico parcialmente por la comunidad
internacional como un estado independiente,
pero Rusia no solo no lo reconoce sino que
cuando se trata de este territorio Moscú
siempre se pone del lado serbio en los organismos
internacionales.
(En cambio, la posición de la Unión Europea
pasa por reconocer la independencia de Kosovo
y hacer ceder a Belgrado.
De hecho una de las condiciones para la adhesión
al club comunitario pasa precisamente porque
Belgrado abandone su beligerancia hacía Kosovo
y ponga en marha un proceso de normalización
de las relaciones bilaterales.
Algo que ni el gobierno ni la propia sociedad
serbia parecen dispuestos a hacer.
Así pues, Rusia se ha convertido en el mayor
valedor en las instituciones internacionaes
de los intereses serbios.)
Luego hay una cosa que os puede sorprender,
y mucho, en esta especie de ambigüedad estratégica
de Serbia: me estoy refiriendo al campo militar.
Serbia es un país que no pertenece ni a la
OTAN ni a su versión rusa, la Organización
del Tratado de Seguridad Colectiva u OTSC,
pero en cambio participa activamente con estas
dos organizaciones al mismo tiempo.
Serbia es Estado observador de la alianza
rusófila, y a la vez miembro del programa
‘Asociación para la Paz’ de la OTAN,
y de hecho participa habitualmente en ejercios
militares de estas dos organizaciones.
Digamos que la neutralidad - o más bien la
ambiguedad - en el campo militar es algo particularmente
importante para Belgrado.
(“No vamos a cambiar nuestra política hacia
Rusia.
Continuaremos con nuestras relaciones de hermandad,
no cambiaremos de política, no nos uniremos
a la OTAN ni a la OTSC.
[...] Serbia tiene su propio ejército para
proteger sus tierras y sus cielos” - Aleksandar
Vučić, presidente de Serbia)
Los que visteis el anterior vídeo, ya sabéis
que entre el 2015 y el 2021 el gobierno serbio
disparó su presupuesto militar más de un
70%, así que las palabras del presidente
no parecen precisamente un farol.
Serbia tiene entre ceja y ceja ser capaces
por sí mismos de garantizar su soberanía.
Al fin y al cabo hablamos de un estatus, de
una apuesta por la ambiguedad que no les ha
ido precisamente mal.
Atentos.
(EL PUENTE SERBIO)
La aceptación oficialmente de la candidatura
de un país para entrar en la Unión Europea
conlleva por sí mismo importantes ventajas,
tanto en el plano económico como en la libre
circulación de personas.
Y el caso de Serbia, obviamente, no es una
expcepción.
Hablamos de ventajas como la exención de
visados para poder viajar, los paques de ayudas
directas o un acceso preferente al mercado
comunitario sin aranceles ni sobrerregulaciones
y barreras para un montón de productos.
(Desde el año 2013, gracias al acuerdo de
estabilización y asociación con la Unión
Europea, un estatus previo a la ahesión,
Serbia tiene un acceso prácticamente libre
al mercado comunitario.
Este acuerdo ha hecho que las exportaciones
de Serbia a la UE se disparen, y actualmente
supongan según el año entre el 58 y el 68
por ciento de todas las ventas al exterior
del país.
Además los países del bloque comunitario
son también los mayores inversores en la
economía serbia.
Desde el año 2010 suponen entre el 60 y el
80% de toda la Inversión Directa Extranjera
que entra cada año en el país.)
En definitiva, una creciente interconexión
que le ha sentado muy bien a la economía
serbia.
Claro que con estos datos en la mano bien
podríamos pensar que en Belgrado están como
locos por terminar de integrarse en la Unión
Europea lo antes posible, ¿verdad?
Pues…
No, lo cierto es que no.
De hecho, en los informes anuales que Bruselas
realiza para informar de los avances en las
reformas económicas, políticas y legislativas
que Serbia tiene que llevar a cabo de cara
a su membresía en la UE, lo que más se repite
es la expresión “escasos avances”.
Y es que justo aquí aparece el punto que
diferencia a Serbia de los otros países balcánicos
que ya han entrado en la UE o están en camino
de hacerlo proximamente: hablamos de la asociación
económica con Rusia y con los aliados de
Rusia.
(Además de mantener un Acuerdo de Estabilización
y Asociación con la UE Serbia también tiene
un estatus de acceso preferente al mercado
de la Unión Económica Euroasiática, el
bloque económico liderado por Moscú que
incluye a Rusia, Bielorrusia, Armenia, Kazajistán
y Kirguistán.
Evidentemente este mercado es mucho, muchísimo
más pequeño que el mercado comunitario,
pero también conlleva una ventaja: el acceso
en condiciones preferentes al sector energético
y a las materias primas.
Y no solo eso.
Otro importante beneficio para Belgrado es
que muchas empresas e inversores occidentales
han apostado precisamente por Serbia para
aprovechar su libre acceso tanto al mercado
europeo como al mercado de la Unión Euroasiática.
De esta forma el país funciona como una especie
de puente entre ambos bloques, lo que ha favorecido
a la por otra parte renqueante economía nacional.)
Empresas occidentales y rusas como por ejemplo
Microsoft, Lukoil, Coca-Cola, Siemens o FIAT
tienen importantes inversiones para aprovechar
el puente económico serbio entre la UE, Rusia
y su órbita.
Y desde luego, otro de los motivos por los
que a Serbia le ha convenido, y mucho, llevarse
bien con Moscú y no entrar en líos con el
Kremlin ha sido su altísima dependencia de
Rusia en materia energética.
Porque si lo de Alemania ya nos puede parecer
escandaloso, las cifras de Serbia van todavía
más allá.
En 2020 las importaciones serbias de gas desde
Rusia suponían el 64% del total, y en el
caso del petróleo crudo y del GLP aún más.
Podemos hablar de más del 75% de las importaciones
energéticas de Serbia.
Una situación que viene de largo y sobre
la que Estados Unidos ha advertido en reiteredadas
ocasiones:
(9 de septiembre de 2016 - EE.UU. urge a Serbia
y Eslovenia a que diversifiquen sus fuentes
de energía - Reuters)
Para más inri, la principal petrolera serbia,
NIS, está controlada por la rusa Gazprom,
que posee el 56,15% de sus acciones.
Porque si en algo se han esforzado los rusos
ha sido precisamente en tener bien atado al
sector energético de Serbio.
Seguro, seguro que no os sorprende.
Y en total, aunque muy lejos de la Unión
Europea, Rusia es el segundo inversor en el
país.
En definitiva, que Belgrado no tiene la menor
prisa por llevar a cabo tooodas las reformas
que pide Bruselas para convertirse en miembro
pleno.
Al fin y al cabo ya disfruta de muchas de
las ventajas del mercado único.
Y desde luego la entrada en la UE supondría
poner punto y final a esa posición de punto
que geopoliticamente hablando tanto interesa
en Belgrado.
Claro que ahora las sanciones internacionales
y el impacto que estas probablemente tengan
en la economía rusa podría cambiar por completo
estos planes y hacer que Serbia se ponga las
pilas para sumarse de una vez por todas a
la Unión Europea.
Sea como sea, los profundos lazos culturales,
históricos, políticos y económicos entre
Serbia y Rusia siembran la duda de si Serbia
no terminaría convirtiéndose en una especie
de caballo de Troya.
Este es un miedo también parece estar creciendo
en Bruselas.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿Crees que Serbia terminará formando parte
de la Unión Europea?
¿Qué opinas de que Belgrado haya optado
por mantener su posición amistosa con el
Kremlin a pesar de la invasión rusa de Ucrania?
Déjanos tu opinión aquí debajo, en los
comentarios.
y si te ha gustado este vídeo no olvides
darle like y suscribirte a nuestro canal.
Una vez más, gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.